welcome back well this week the Lib Dems
teamed up with a green party and Pleiku
Murray to form a remain alliance which
means that each party will throw their
weight behind just one candidate in 60
constituencies across the UK to try and
get more anti-fur exit MPs elected well
joining us now is one of those who's
hoping to benefit from the deal the
Liberal Democrats education spokesperson
at around thank you very much good
morning on the program and talk to me
about this remain aligned some people
want to look at this and think this is
just an attempt to try and rig and
Stitch on democracy not at all I mean we
have first past the post electoral
system where if in this brexit election
this elections been called because of
brexit this is the biggest issue that we
are going to be discussing in this
election and it is the unite to remain
initiative and if you want to know who
is the remain candidate in your seat
then it gives a clear steer for that in
the 60 seats I should say in 2017 when I
won the seat off the Conservatives
overturned a nearly 10,000 majority the
Greens stood aside in that election and
it worked and I won by just 816 votes so
we've proven that in the past it can
work and actually what this also is is
people are just sort of sick of the
party politics the rough-and-tumble this
is these is party these parties are
making a compromise I mean the fact is
in very many seats the Lib Dems might be
the actual second place right now with
the way the polling is going but
actually we are stepping down for the
greens for plied so that we can you know
have more grown-up politics you say this
is a brexit election but is it all about
practicing I mean many some have been
voters I'm sure waited to leave the
absolutely people vote Lib down and
other parties the whole raft of reasons
for all kinds of things that they feel
really passionately about here we need
to say that actually breaks it's the
most important issues so any other
reason that you might be interested in
voting Lib Dem we're not interested not
at all I mean of course people out there
well and you know all the parties are
are standing on you know different forms
of what we're going to do about brexit
for the Liberal Democrats it's stop
brexit and hence the remain message but
it is about more than that you know
today we're announcing our new Universal
childcare policy I'm education
spokesperson I'm excited to talk about
schools and yes this will all get mixed
up but to suggest that bricks that isn't
going to play in people's minds during
this election I think
you know this is why we are here I mean
if you look at for example a guy called
mike Powell the Welsh Liberal Democrat
candidate in Ponty Prix he doesn't want
to stand a solid four PyCon race been
told he has to he says he doesn't want
to who's gonna stand as an independent
and if you look at his reasons for doing
that I mean he says and makes a point
that plica Murray want to take Wales out
of the rest of the United Kingdom they
were independence he says if the Welsh
national party are in these are really
big issues you can see where he's coming
from yeah and what we're very clear
about is that this isn't somehow all the
parties getting together and becoming
one I mean the Green Party candidates in
2017 and my seats it out you know I'm a
Green Party member I'm a green person I
stand proud for my what my party stands
for but we recognize that if we are
going to in my case unseat a
Conservative MP and get someone in there
who's going to represent our
constituency on the key issue of brexit
then this is what you have to do it
doesn't mean that the Liberal Democrats
are suddenly saying that we agree with
harsh independence we don't and what we
often say in what we and and we asked
and they're doing the same for us and
you know they probably don't agree with
everything that we stand for either but
what we say to people is you know in the
end no party owns voters voters are
going to make their own decision and we
often say you know would you lend your
vote to another party in this first past
the post system that doesn't allow for
that Bret that we have now in party
politics and that's what we're
suggesting now you mentioned in a little
bit earlier at the childcare
announcement I just explained to have
you is water is that Lib Dems wanted yet
so it's 35 hours of free childcare
properly funded high-quality free
childcare for 48 weeks of the year that
would cover everyone from two to four
years old but where ours is radically
different even to labour who are
announcing similar things today is it
also covers that gap for working parents
between the nine months of age until too
many families across the country feel
that they have no choice but to go back
to work the average cost of sending a
child from age two it's nine months to
two years old to twenty five hours as
six and a half thousand pounds a year
that's a lot of money so man how much is
this policy gonna cost so in total it's
fourteen point six billion it's sorry
fourteen fourteen point six it's a very
expensive policy and we're being very
upfront about that it's really costed
and would be paid for you say it cost
over because I read the
press release and and it just said it
will be funded by fair tax changes so
how will it be fun so we've got a
corporation tax rise back to the 20%
that it was before the Conservatives
took it down and then we've also got
taxing wealth in the same line as income
together those bring in about 16 billion
pounds so it more than covers what we're
suggesting okay okay and now Sky News
has proposed a three-way debate in this
election campaign between Joe Swenson
Jeremy Corbyn and Boris Johnson and Joe
Swanson says she wants to sum up and do
it and we've also got these two
head-to-head debates going on what's
your position on whether or not the
other party should take part yeah well I
want to say thank you to Sky 4 I think
representing what most people out there
want which is that all the voices that
are representing the whole breadth the
brexit debate are in there Joe Swanson
is unequivocally ambitious about her
plan to be Prime Minister and she would
be a brilliant Prime Minister we are the
biggest strongest remain party fielding
candidates in all parts of the UK and
actually were the only party that can
challenge labour and the Conservatives
on this we are in discussions with
lawyers about what we're going to do
with the itv debate and we're also
looking at court action for the BBC one
- and you're looking at correction that
BBC - and well they would argue I guess
that and they're two people with a
biggest chance of being Prime Minister
would be Jeremy Corbyn and Boris Johnson
and that they're also doing another
debate they would argue it's the biggest
possibly chance you could argue actually
in a four-way split that we're seeing in
this election that you know anything can
happen but also they're not the only
people with that chance and voters need
to be able to hear from everyone so I'm
delighted that sky can see that can see
that actually having a remain voice in
those debates is critical and it is
absolutely right that that stop meant
stop brexit message should be delivered
by Joe Swanson
do you really think that Joe Swinson
could end up in number 10 I think in
this election and that's you know no
one's saying this isn't a huge mountain
to climb no one is pretending that it's
not but what we did see is that in the
Europeans different electoral system I
get it but we polled higher than the
Conservatives and the Labour Party for
the first time in a hundred years there
is something weird happening in British
politics right now it's showing itself
in the last few months anything is
possible
I'm not saying that it's not a stretch
target it is but
for once I actually genuinely think it
is possible you see I am a bit baffled
I'll be honest I'll ever with you about
why the Lib Dems are pushing the idea
that she could be Prime Minister I know
you want to show you've got momentum but
really is this not also about
expectation management are you really
saying that Joe Swinson who has got what
20 MPs now could it be end up in number
times Prime Minister what we're doing is
is presenting people with that real
choice and making them realise that
actually these are quite interesting
circle she could I think that she could
I do at other elections I would have
held back from that but given the
volatility of politics right now and if
we have that big uptight uptick in the
polls which could happen in a general
election in a forward four-way split
under the first-past-the-post system I
mean all these things come together and
suddenly it's not so outlandish actually
it is entirely possible